we do have a fun very fun show for you
this evening that you're gonna have a
great time tonight or if you're from
Napa Valley you're going to have a grape
wine tonight a joke that really that
just didn't work at all
yeah that that was not a good one that
joke just didn't give me that give me
that yeah no man this is just this is as
written I just read what was written and
that is just hold on a second hello if
you know the name of the department you
need please say it at any time returns
and exchanges I'm sorry I couldn't hear
that returns and exchanges returns and
exchanges this is Britta kaha may I
assist you see your lights just came on
[Applause]
terrific uh but yeah turn I would like
to return a joke okay and was this joke
for home or professional use a
professional use
Oh are you one of those mommy bloggers
no no I'm not a mommy blogger I host a
late-night talk show oh that's exciting
like Carson Daly and what Network are
you on NBC ABC CBS oh all right I'll
just put four semi-professional use do
you have the receipt receipt no nobody
saves receipts okay I'm sorry but
without a receipt I'm gonna have to get
my manager hold please why not give the
gift of laughter with a joke from our
Sweetheart collection hello was there a
problem with one of our jokes yeah it
doesn't work I think it's defective he
doesn't have a receipt it's a man sir
are you altering your voice no I am NOT
yes I'm a man can you please just help
me that's what I'm trying to do sir
could you tell us the joke sure I was
saying our audience was going to have a
great time tonight or if you're from
Napa Valley you're going to have a grape
wine tonight sir is it possible you
delivered it wrong did you remember to
pretend to drink a glass of wine yes I
followed all the instructions I did that
and it didn't help well with no receipt
we can only exchange the joke for one of
equal or lesser value fine fine it looks
like I can offer you a slightly used
John Oliver rant about nectarine
price-fixing in South America you get
really angry at these no no no that's I
don't do that I don't that's not my
thing
okay well all right at that price point
I can only offer you something from our
barely political collection but we can
customize it to your show just tell me
who your guests are tonight okay first
guess I've got Kevin Nealon and then I
have Martin Freeman perfect I have got
just the thing
and you button for its green or
goldenrod goldenrod please oh great I'll
brush it right out okay and have a great
time with it or if you live in Napa
Valley have a great wine with it
when you do it it's not a Joe where
that's good that's good okay I'm Sam
with it oh hey thanks for mrs. O'Brien
its mr. O'Brien oh great fantastic thank
you very much okay it's quick oh this
would be great there you go right there
fantastic thank you alright ladies and
gentlemen as I say we got a great show
from the CBS series man with a plan
actor and comedian Kevin Nealon is on I
just I just I just hope Trump doesn't
catch him Kevin Nealon during the
national anthem
yeah
you
you